so today my talk is gonna be about fuzzy
search algorithms this is a ipython
notebook and you can follow along on
github if you choose to do so so quickly
Who am I
my name is Josh Leo I am a data
scientist at Capital One I'm based out
of the New York office most of my work
is at the intersection of data science
and engineering and we work with big
data tools and machine learning so fuzzy
search algorithms I'm sure a lot of you
are familiar with the concept of yeah
yes
okay I'll hang out here for a little bit
so yeah there's a a Python notebook and
that github repo and all the outputs are
there so you'll be spoiled if you take a
look now but you can also run it by
installing the requirements dot tech
stuff in there all right so most of you
are probably familiar at some level with
the concept of fuzzy search or fuzzy
match so it's the idea that you know
strings are not always search based on
whether or not they're identical but
rather based on some kind of similarity
measurement so I like to think of this
as like the distance between words or
the distance between strings you know in
the concept of data science we usually
try to quantify as much of our data as
possible and try to when we're building
models we like to have numerical values
and the fuzzy search element is one
component and cleansing the data and
making it quantified enough that you can
use it to build models so today I'd like
to talk through the soundex algorithm
Levenstein engrams and then later at the
end a little bit into
similarity concept for for words in
terms of where to effect and an ltk for
synonyms so very quickly sound acts
pretty straightforward it's a phonetic
algorithm and its indexing words by
sound as pronounced in English and it
assigns a sound that's coding value
which you can then use to do a lot of
your calculations its idea for spelling
inconsistencies less so for searching
semantic search but it's more so ideal
for like messy data in general uh the
algorithm is pretty straightforward here
it is you assign numerical values to
certain letters and you typically ignore
all the vowels because it is pretty
simple you can tweak it and implement it
yourself
I have redownload it a library and
Python and that's what I will walk
that's due today so I downloaded this
jellyfish library which actually has a
lot of really great packages and tools
for the different algorithms I'm going
to talk about today so as you can see
here because the detection of the
algorithm is to ignore vowels the value
for the sound x value for washington and
what the a and i'm Washington with the U
is identical yes
sure so going back to the slide the
algorithm itself is going through the
string and checking for Dedes letters
where they see these letters it gets
paired up to one of these numbers it's
obviously not like a direct mapping and
then it tosses out the vowels so the
letters are associated with the
particular sound if you wanna think
about it that way so for abbreviations
like LGA versus LaGuardia you can see
that they're very they're different but
they're still similar enough that you
can do a comparison off with them and
then because sound apps is so tailored
towards the English language and also
towards letters it doesn't really
account for numbers and non ASCII
characters so in this situation word
number one two three and word are
absolutely identical according to 10x
something else it handles which i think
is pretty interesting is how I interpret
homonyms so these two actually have the
same like numerical value but because
they start with different letters are
different and accept and accept to sound
alike same for four and forth because
they are different words entirely with
different meanings but they sound saying
they have the same sound x value so I
work a lot with Python pi also work a
lot with Postgres and in Postgres
there's this built-in fuzzy search
expansion that allows you to query your
data using sound X instead of using a
normal you know where this field equals
this thing
so here is the this is the example that
I pulled from the postbag Postgres
documentation so comparing the sound
that speaking and and and with the E and
a Madonna II and calculating and
difference something interesting to know
here is the difference is four and that
seems kind of counterintuitive why is
the difference such a large number when
you know these two words have the exact
same sound x value and that goes to
again this is straight from the
documentation for focus class the
difference between the sound x values
actually ranges from 0 to 4 and a 4 is
an exact match so that's something to
keep in mind so I have a in my local
Postgres instance I have a table with
some misspelled cities in it and this
query will allow me to use down X to
search for those miss Feld City values
yeah so when I search for exact match I
get three variations of Washington DC
from my database
yeah
yeah that's a really good play I was
gonna bring that up later about happy to
address it now so usually this fuzzy
search would be one component or one
feature of some model you're building so
things like common misspellings that you
know of based on whatever it is is your
domain expertise that would probably be
end up being another feature Anja ham
one of the reasons I like sound X and
one the algorithms I'll show later is it
is relatively straightforward to
implement so you don't actually have to
use a library and you can decide to
implement your own variation of sound x
to account for whatever scenarios are
specific to your use cases all right let
me run this free cannoned so this query
is specifying for a difference greater
than sorry I this quarry is slightly
different from the previous one is s but
instead of 40 for an exact match now we
wants a difference in sound acts of
greater than 2 and when I actually
compile the query string this is what I
get from my list and here I've sort of
relaxed what the standards are for Emacs
match if I change that to 1 I got a much
bigger list if I changed that to 3 I go
back to I think what I had previously
which is these 3 iterations that match
at a pretty high confidence level
alright I went on CARICOM and I
downloaded some of Hillary Clinton's
emails
for for fun and I studded the inherent
subject hotline I want to search for
variations of when she talked about
guitar and these are sort of the matches
I get along let me up that confidence
level and see what I get
yeah yeah I think for Cairo
things she talks about that line it was
doing because sound acts doesn't
actually do I guess it's looking for
that particular sound so when there's
other strings appended to it it doesn't
actually search for it so let me see if
there's any mentions of the hell are you
thing about very interesting all right
the pros of sound acts it's super easy
to implement so you can implement your
own version it's computationally fast
which is really great for doing
real-time analysis it does only work on
ASCII characters so no foreign languages
and no very symbols and doesn't really
deal with numbers it doesn't really
specify how you calculate the distance
between two strings which is sometimes a
pro and sometimes a con you can then
take it and do whatever you want with it
based on whatever you your use cases are
but also it is very open-ended which
brings us to the next topic which is the
levenshtein distance yeah so postcards
obviously have its own like difference
definition but that's just a number from
zero to four and if I didn't look into
exactly what that algorithm is like but
yeah I think the idea is that you should
use your own distance metric alright so
for Levenstein also known as at a
distance it counts for how many
characters would you have to change to
obtain the same string it's also called
additionally fast and it requires a
pairwise comparison so again here I did
not implement this on my own I chose to
download a Python package so Smith and
Smith the the sound x value would
probably be very similar and the lemma
Steyn distance is to four
it's like context I am using Python 3 so
I do have utf-8 or Unicode encoding for
my strings and tap a with the accent
versus cafe is two different words with
and it will require one character change
to to become the same one so it's one
slight problems would lemma Stein or
maybe they're not they're not really
problems if depending on your UK use
case but in as humans we know that when
we look at addresses 99 Broadway is
really close to 100 bad way and that 999
Broadway is probably really far from the
both of them but if I use Levenstein to
to make this comparison the 99 Broadway
on 100 Broadway they are at three lemon
signed distances away because you have
to change three of the characters and
that is okay I lost a Python so but if
you look at
so by show of 99 Broadway and 999
Broadway they are at a distance of one
because you will only need to insert one
more 9 to get that so they're actually
closer than 99 versus 100 and this is
you know based on how you interpret the
string but that is a one of the aspects
of not not always using the naively
built package but maybe creating your
own version of lemon sky or your own
version of sound accounts for these
specific use cases that you might care
about okay the other thing is how lemon
shy handles longer strings so in this
scenario hello world comma Python it's
great hello well come up pythons good
the distance is 4 because you have to
change for the characters there but it
within a larger strain contacts that
number means something different than
here where if you just compare great
versus good that is also a four so
something you would do to account for
this is we typically would weigh the
sound the levenshtein distance against
the length of this string to get a more
accurate measurement of that I cannot
pronounce this the the Amero Levenstein
distance the leveraged i only accounts
for inserts deletions this version of
rubbish i essentially will count for
transposition and in addition to inserts
dalish deletions and and character I
guess swaps so as you can see here I
often misspelled the word receive which
is why I am using it as an example this
will have a distance of one and then for
the regular Levenstein you will actually
have at this
of two because in that algorithm you are
switching out one character here and
then like character there so here's what
you have two characters whereas here
you're making one transposition swap so
this can definitely be useful in a lot
of different use cases and again it
depends on what your end goal is okay
so lunch time super fat so again I have
this tiny like bio of misspelled city
names and I can go through and just
calculate leverage sign justice for all
them and it's any questions before I
keep doing all right
so Ngram slash trigram it takes into you
so we're already seeing that adding
context into a string with the Tres
positions is it's pretty interesting and
adds another dimension to this kind of
analysis but with try ground and Engram
in general there is another layer of
taking into the context of what is
around the string so groupings of
letters you can decide what proper unit
of analysis is right for you
the cons are it is a little bit slower
to not really to implement but slower to
do the calculations that so you will
have to calculate the Engram for every
one of your strings so I wrote this tiny
function to break up two tokenize my
where it slash strings there's a lot of
Python packages that will have these
things built-in so in the in the
sentence example you would separate out
your sentences into blocks of words and
those are your engrams in the worst
example you will suffer out your engrams
into blocks
characters so the scoring similarity
that I've been using in this is also
I'll sort of show how trigram is handle
and post west this is also the scoring
similarity that Postgres uses this de
Jaccard similarity and it is the
division between the number of
intersections of the trigrams and number
of unions so let me not so keep in mind
in the previous slide
I ran the trigram for I generated a
triangle from PI day to DC so when I
compare against each other I'll get a
score 1.0 because they are exactly
identical and trigrams are also
identical if I compare against the
received data without an eye and you see
date those are two distinct strings by
preparing the trigrams score on that one
it's fine five yep
that's a really great question yes
so yes why wouldn't you do something
like cosine similarity um so we're two
back actually uses cosine similarity to
measure the distance between and the the
problem so obviously using cosine
similarity is great but then you
actually have to convert your trigrams
int or your string of rams into some
vector so you had the vector idea for
its firsthand so I bring out word to
that yeah those nine similarity is
another way to a really common way to
compare similarity between two strings
alright so again
Postgres has a extension for where try
exam and I have my database full of
misspelled city names
so just to be the query and sorry do you
I don't want to go through it too fast
but um the syntax here is I'm converting
all my strings to in the database to
lowercase so that comparing against my
string which I've also just use
lowercase letters and it will give me a
similarity score and this is the special
trigrams syntax which will only work if
you install the alright so and going
back to looking for rare and this is the
Washington DC I can read this query and
so if you remember earlier when I did
soundex on a database and this is the
same data set there were three instances
of Washington DC and now there's four
because the trigram I can actually pick
up this last one that has no spacing on
it and the other column is the fragments
for given to me by the similarity
function
all right going back to Hillary's emails
just slightly bigger dataset I look for
our secretary she's the Secretary of
State there's a lot of mentions of
Secretary of State if I for out see what
else shall I look for in close emails I
think I have another I don't know I
don't
okay I think they were much as could
okay which I'm definitely not spelling
right oh no because I'm definitely not
spending that long right all right let's
try Qatar and there's a specific matched
it up alright some things to know the
the datasets I'm working with are not
large doors I have like 5,000 emails
from the hell are you to say those are
not really large datasets if you're
actually working with a much larger data
set that Postgres of these just engine
and this e is for trigrams and it will
pre Calais Oh pre calculate the trigrams
for certain fields for out of the fuel
you want to index on and they're really
useful for speeding up the query yep
yeah
so that sounds a lot like doing semantic
search and in my experience which I
don't cover this in the top today is
it's Lucene search is really fast I
think there's another talk later about
elastic search either tomorrow but
elastic search is also really good for
for querying and doing semantic search
all right so other is similarity metrics
so we've mostly been talking about
string distances in terms of the
characters of the string and how that
relates to the distance between two two
words but another metric that is super
interesting to quantify is not the not
just the characters of that contain that
are contained in string but rather the
meaning of the word itself and that
brings me to to the natural language
toolkit at with Python and we're not as
well as word Tyvek which uses again
cosine dispenses between two vectors and
actually factorizes your word for a
little further analysis so we're net
will give you a similarity and next
between two words so the colors are
actually always going to be close
together because they're sort of used in
the same context if you do semi
unrelated things you'll know that these
two things are are different and I'm
using a corpus that is go into NLT Kay
but if you were doing specific things on
your own you can always generate your
own corpus and also use whatever
scenarios whatever models actually fit
your use case
okay where did that so I downloaded this
sample dataset here it does require you
to sort of tree process and train the
model a little bit I'm not gonna run
this because it takes some time and I
have in the cooking show style generator
for myself and a background so I'm just
going to magically go to the next slide
where everything's all ready to go so
loading the model I can then get a
vector form of the the word that I'm
searching so in this case coffee this is
what the vector representation according
to word to that is yeah so I don't
really know like what that means and I
can do a lot with it once my word is in
vector form so here I can use cosine
distance to get a list of words that are
close to the word coffee and these are
the distance metrics and these are the
words associated with it so this is
definitely interesting and also it's
before a lot of definitely a lot of
modeling applications sorry I meant to
yeah I meant to run I'll sue email on
the topic of email it's actually
interesting because it has all these
words associated with the like FTP and
browser okay so that is um generally
yeah that that is it I'm happy to take
questions again all the material that I
show today is on github yes
yeah so I want to caveat that way
I must leave work with supervised
learning models so we usually either
hand pureed some sort of label data set
or we obtain it from the trusted source
and what we would do is we would run our
models we will calibrate our models
against that training data and that also
measure our models based on that it's
definitely really tricky in the sense
that you can never engage in a large
production scale system you can never
get a I guess get the true measurement
of accuracy you can only estimate
accuracy so that is something that you
sort of get to a point where you use
these like values that are generated by
these algorithms to - in your models and
then at the end result you sort of have
to know that ok I'm 95% confident of
this algorithm or I'm 75% confident and
it's depen depends a lot on what your
tolerance is and sometimes maybe your
search isn't as great and you you don't
get a lot of value um maybe you don't
get a lot of strings out of it because
you're not willing to tolerate a lower
level of confidence and that's I think
that is definitely that's not a problem
like that's not unique to this situation
particular that's very common data
science I hope that helps a little bit
all right and get our questions yep
oh that address mapping yeah so I just
give that as an example on the
limitations on Levenstein I would if I
were comparing addresses what I would
actually do is you know turn them into
lat/long and then compare them as
numbers that way but it is it is a
challenge because so addresses there
they won't always be spelled the same
way sometimes like Street what we've
spelled out sometimes they'll be
abbreviated sometimes it's various ways
of reading creating different things so
that is where the dish the actual fuzzy
search component will come in in that
scenario what we would typically do is
write our own xi should I or whatever
like Korea are with them in such a way
that it discounts for things like
numbers and symbols cool any other
questions
yep
oh yeah I'm gonna go back and actually
Brenda yeah so it is different
um again like it's not framed on a
specific data set it's not like a it's a
deterministic lookup so it just sort of
knows that these letters are supposed to
be with this town and therefore this is
the result I should be producing yep
yeah so I can tell you that soundex is
not calibrated to any particular dialect
or variation of the language again it's
a very deterministic model and this is
these sounds are supposed to be the same
and attribute it this way and it's
dictated by the American sound that this
coding standards but it is definitely
interesting to to look at data from the
perspective oh no maybe different people
would to put these pronunciations
differently and in that situation you
would probably have to build your own
model that there could still have
aspects of sound X so or maybe have like
different deterministic mappings
depending on what dialects you're
exploring